[Music]
hi my name is Hannah Dickinson and this
is cheers to you where I'm kicking up my
first round of the weekend by cheering
to all the people and stories that
encouraged me to drink cheers to you
post Malone for selling out your line of
Crocs in ten minutes
they sold out almost as fast as you did
cheers to you Oh Jay Simpson for
dressing as a gynecologist for Halloween
oh look another bloody glove cheers to
you alec baldwin for claiming you act
out only when provoked way to take the
high road let's hope it has parking
cheers to you Spice Girls for going on a
reunion tour it warms my heart to see
four of my childhood heroes run out of
money at the exact same time cheers to
you Bill Gates for reinventing the
toilet also known as Windows 8 it was
terrible cheers to you man without pants
who fell through a Waffle House ceiling
that's the joke incredible cheers - Zayn
Malik for admitting you didn't make
friends while in one direction no
boy bands are strictly for making music
making money and making children you
refuse to go public about half of 98
degrees at Lowe's make a phone call
cheers to you Facebook for creating a
pop-up store it will be filled with
items you mentioned to your friend one
time over the phone how convenient
oh my god this store sells vibrators and
pepto-bismol
welp that's it for cheers to you be sure
to check out our regular show every damn
day where this week I drank a hundred
bottled salt doll your bottle dollar
$100 bottle of wine and we watch the
best clips from the Chappelle show why
can't I speak do I have a speech
impediment or am i drunk we don't know
Cheers
[Music]